when I talk to people about seeing all
kinds of wildlife they're always amazed
and they say they go into forests or a
park here wooded area to take pictures
of wildlife or birds and they don't see
anything so come along and I'll show you
how to build your own natural blind for
free well this looks like a good spot
let me check it out I've broken up my
outline that's good it's in a shadow
that's really good
all I need to do is kind of remodel it
I'm going to go break some vegetation
and some dead sticks and kind of give me
a little bit more shadow what I'm doing
out here in the forest is the same thing
you might do in your garden when you
just prune your shrubbery a little bit
so a bit like this they get pruned all
the time by storms and wind branches
falling out of trees
they simply regrow their greenery so I'm
going to basically plant some shrubbery
kind of an irregular pattern just like
nature this will kind of camouflage my
movement
I don't really want this to be a wall of
obstacles I want it to be kind of spread
out so you can actually see through it
but it just kind of defers your eye when
you glance at it and creates more shadow
I'm going to look at this from the
animals perspective and see what they
see it needs a little bit more
camouflage so I'm going to go from the
inside now and dress up the inside of my
little blind what I'm looking for is
when I'm sitting back here if I hear
noise that way or hear a sound of an
animal there a footprint I want to be
able to move around a little bit and
turn my head without catching the
animals high in the smallest movement of
these lease is natural in the forest so
they're going to see that instead of
seeing my ears or my eyes moving then
I've got my blind built I've got my body
camouflaged I'm calm down I'm just going
to sit and wait for the animals to come